I'm Mike Johns I'm a data scientist at
hellofresh thanks for coming I'm gonna
talk about propensity score matching
which is a non experimental approach to
trying to accomplish causal inference
just a little about my little bit about
myself
data scientist is now the fourth leg a
very long career I've had using data and
analytic methods to answer questions and
solve problems I started off as an
experimental psychologist torturing
undergraduates and P hacking a lot I
went onto epidemiology worked for the
city for many years did Policy Research
and most recently have made the leap
into data science proper so this is a
topic that comes from my home field of
the Social and Behavioral Sciences so
just a quick outline I'll start off with
a kind of overview propensity score
matching in a nutshell and then get into
the specifics talk about how to
calculate a propensity score which
involves building a model selecting
covariance how to use those scores to
then perform matching in order to find a
comparison group and then if there's
time I'll briefly touch on estimating
treatment effects that's actually a
pretty complex topic in and of itself
that we could spend a couple of hours
talking about so I'll do a lot of hand
waving there okay so propensity score
matching this is a quasi experimental
method that is designed to help you find
a control group in a situation where
random assignment is impossible so
you're using this propensity to be
exposed to something let's say it's a
marketing campaign some new policy some
new law as a proxy for assignment to a
condition as you would in an experiment
so it's a pretty common method in social
behavioral sciences gets used a lot in
educational research economy Trish ins
are probably pretty familiar with it it
was developed the original theory was
developed by Don Rubin and Paul
Rosenbaum
back in the 80s so it naturally fits
within the the social behavioral science
world and it's basically founded on this
idea that the key to drawing causal
inferences is based on this idea for
groups in a study treatment and non
treated groups to be balanced
essentially to be equivalent on average
and this is an idea that comes from the
potential outcomes framework that Rubin
has also been heavily involved in and so
the idea is that you want exposure to be
independent of any observed or
unobserved background characteristics
all right so you can make an inference
that any differences between groups are
based solely on exposure to some
treatment or condition now this method
is best suited for dealing with
selection bias which is just a
pre-existing tendency to behave in a
certain way expose yourself to certain
material and so forth cannot necessarily
eliminate other types of confounds so
the list I have here history maturation
regression I mean these are all have a
temporal aspect to them and so this
isn't necessarily a solution to dealing
with all potential sources of confound
in a observational study situation so
let's say we have a situation I often
find myself in we I work for hellofresh
we sell food probably makes sense that
we want to put some advertising up on
the Food Network right and in the ideal
situation we would have some means of
controlling who sees that ad who doesn't
see that si sees that ad and then maybe
after some time seven days 14 days 21
days we look to see of the people that
saw the ad how many show up as customers
and of those who didn't how many showed
up and the difference between those two
conversion outcomes ends up being our
estimate of lift or a treatment effect
unfortunately the real world is not so
convenient or cooperative so oftentimes
all we know is who saw the ad and who
didn't we had no control over whether or
not they were assigned to see it or not
and so almost certainly we have a case
where we have
a confounding situation based on
selection bias so people who are
interested in cooking almost certainly
are gonna be more likely to watch the
Food Network especially if they have
cable and then by that fact more likely
be exposed to the ad and almost
certainly they're probably just more
likely to become a customer of
hellofresh if they're interested in
cooking right so this is the classic
classic illustration of selection
problem so we have background variables
in this case we have a latent variable
that is related to both the chance of
being exposed to the ad and the outcome
itself now typically we don't have
access to this latent variable we have
information about other variables or
factors that are related to this thing
of interest so demographic
characteristics past behavior
psychographics that we talked about in
the world of marketing but what we
really want is this situation right we
want to sever that relationship between
these confounds these selection biases
and exposure to the ads so that when we
look at the difference between those
people who saw the ad in those who
didn't we are not that inference isn't
gonna be confused or confounded by the
fact that the people who saw the ad are
just different to begin with okay so
those of you are familiar with sort of
causal graph the work of Jude Pearl will
know this as the back door problem right
so we want to shut that back door and
propensity score matching is basically
just one way to try and accomplish this
so there's four key steps here you first
have to calculate the propensity score
so you're gonna build a predictive model
and and the model you're building is
predicting the probability of exposure
for those both those people who let's
say in this case saw the advertisement
and didn't see the advertisement then
we're gonna use that score to create a
match control group for the exposed
group we're gonna check that that
matching actually accomplished balance
right it made the group's equivalent on
average and then we're going to estimate
a treatment effect based on this
matching so for those of you like
equations or this kind of
formulation so propensity score is
pretty simply just the probability of
being exposed to some treatment let's
say it's an advertisement or what have
you
conditioned on some set of covariance so
covariance basically means variables
features if you like background
variables and so forth so again it could
be average age in a household number of
people in a household median income
things like that
and so it's basically you're predicting
the probability of being exposed and
then you're gonna use that probability
to find what are unexposed units that
are very similar to the exposed units so
basically your goal here is to build a
model of the selection process and
essentially one idea that I really like
is it what a propensity score is doing
is it's taking all this background
information
it's just condensing it down to one
scaler right and that's actually gonna
allow make it a little bit easier for
you to find similar people households
units and so forth and what you're
trying to do is again optimize balance
between the groups optimize average
equivalence so that you can make
selection strongly ignored in the world
in the words of causal inference so for
all the data scientists in the room I
will call out what you're not doing is
trying to build the most predictive
model that then is going to generalize
to unseen data right it's a slightly
different what we're really building
here is a descriptive model not a
predictive model so just to illustrate
that on the left you have your classic
kind of machine learning ideal where you
have your positive cases and ideally you
have the probability mass pushed all the
way up against one and for your negative
cases right probably the lady Mouse
pushed it all the way up again zero and
very little overlap here between the two
groups right now I'm not saying it
always works out this way we would love
it to work out that way but this is what
we're going for and the propensity score
situation we're actually looking for
some overlap and you still probably want
that unexposed probability pushed up
against here
but for your exposed group it's almost
ideal to have a nice spread across the
different propensity 'z because that
space that common support there that's
where you're gonna find your your
matches for your exposed group so when
it comes to building this propensity
score model predicting who's exposed who
isn't there predicting the probability
of exposure one of the key things that
comes up a lot literature is in building
the model is capturing the proper
functional form of the relationship
between these background variables on
your population and the outcome and so
typically this is a question of are
there complex interactions that you're
missing are there nonlinear
relationships and so forth
despite that typically what people use
is logistic regression it's pretty
simple handy tool there's some limited
research on more sort of traditional
machine learning models random forests
and boosting it typically doesn't seem
to give you any advantage except in the
case maybe not surprisingly if you have
a lot of non-linearity non-additive ax T
which are regression assumptions so for
the most part logistic regression
usually gets the job done and then sort
of jumping back a little bit in in terms
of thinking about how you're
constructing this model and what's going
into what are your covariance as they're
called what are your predictors so
really again you're trying to build this
model of the selection process so your
predictors should ideally be related to
that selection process and in US and
really you're looking for what you could
call true confounders things that are
going to predict exposure as well as the
outcome and generally you also want to
try to avoid avoid what are called
instrumental variables the economists in
the room will know what I'm talking
about so these are variables that are
related to exposure but actually not
related to the outcome and so of course
this is a quasi experimental method and
your ability to get a real unbiased
estimate here depends on finding and
including key variables or key features
that are going to
sure that selection process so omitting
variables is is something of great
concern now generally I would advocate
when you're thinking about how do you
build this model what variables do you
include is really having a theory of
selection okay so hopefully you have
some domain knowledge you have some
domain expertise that you can draw on to
think about the problem that you're
faced with in terms of what are the the
characteristics of people or households
that are going to increase the
likelihood that they see an ad for your
product and also just become a customer
without exposure to any advertising so
along those lines past behaviors are
great to include anything that happened
before the exposure demographics
attitudes Geographic related variables
probably one of the better ones is any
pre exposure values you have on the
outcome you're gonna predict if that's
if that's possible that usually is more
relevant in a case let's say in a
business case maybe if you have a
product that people perch purchase over
time multiple times in terms of
unobserved variables and this is really
the the big shortcoming here is by
definition they're unobserved but this
is where having a theoretical model can
be helpful to think about what is it
that's likely to create selection bias
I try to think about are there proxies
for that data or that variable that I
could use in the model so the world I
work in the world of marketing you have
all these third-party data providers
they purport to give you data on things
like interest in camping or interest in
magazines or what have you how good
those data actually are is is an open
question but there are potential sources
out there that you could use to try and
get to things that are more sort of
latent most of the time so interests
propensity z' proclivities things like
that so this next point I make very
cautiously so typically over including
variables is not going to be a huge
problem because remember we're not
technically worried about
fitting here that said overfitting
generally not a good thing
we want to be careful about
multicollinearity but this is a case
where you can probably if you're not
sure you want to over include here you
can draw on more traditional data
science or sort of statistical learning
methods and use a regularization maybe
do some variable selection and then
calibrate your probabilities just to be
safe okay so once you've built the model
you have your probability or propensity
for your exposed graphic unexposed group
now you're gonna have to do some
matching and again the idea here is that
you have the population is scored you
match and essentially you're trying to
find this set of overlapped overlapping
groups that have similar propensity x'
both in pairs and across the entire
group so the matching algorithms there's
a whole literature on this and we could
spend an hour talking about different
approaches but the three core dimensions
that you see are how greedy is here is
your matching algorithm as a greedy or
is it optimal whether you put
constraints on the distance so do you
set a caliper or do you let it be open
through nearest neighbor and then
cemetery one to one versus one to many
just quickly to walk through these so in
the greedy approach right you're just
iterating through you're looking for the
best match you're gonna seize on that
stop and exit so in this case if we
imagine we were looking for a match that
was in with about 10% of our exposed and
we started from the top we might get to
0.5 607 say that's great
it's in my range I'm taking that one and
I'm exiting even though technically the
best match the closest match might be
down here an optimal we're looking to
minimize the total within pair
difference so this is a more traditional
optimization problem where you're going
to go through the entire list of exposed
you're gonna try and find the best match
for every every pair and then optimize
across the whole group
um caliper versus nearest-neighbor this
one's a little tricky so caliper is
basically just saying you're gonna set
some define limits on how close the
match needs to be so again if we stick
with an example we're looking for let's
say it about a 10% match we could pick
any of these four here highlighted as a
potential match nearest neighbor
obviously you're looking for the closest
match but given the circumstances you
could end up with a very close match or
you could end up with a very far match
there's no limit placed on how near or
far the neighbor actually has to be and
then one-to-one one-to-many pretty
self-explanatory so the general
recommendation that comes out of the
literature usually what people do they
match on the logit of the propensity
score they set a caliper right so they
set a limit on how close the match has
to be to so the match in the exposed
group how close has to be to the
unexposed and it's used about 25 percent
of a standard deviation in terms of
greedy versus nearest neighbor or gree
versus optimal there's not a lot of
evidence on on which one performs better
and when a greedy algorithm is going to
give you better balance between groups
and that's ultimately what you're after
but there can be some instances where
optimal is is a better approach and then
really when it comes to one to one
versus one to many it depends on the
support level in a lot of ways so how
how much overlap is there between the
propensity zuv your unexposed and
exposed groups so unfortunately this is
an area where there's really no sort of
silver bullet or magic bullet solution I
don't know which one it's the right
metaphor it's really going to depend on
your situation it's gonna depend on how
much the scores the propensity scores
themselves overlap which is going to
depend in somewhat on the class balance
imbalance and then also the baseline
difference between your covariance how
big of those differences in the two
groups so once you do your match you
have your exposed group you have a
matched group of unexposed that you're
now going to be your control so now you
need to check to see did the matching
work did you achieve balance did you
reduce those pre-existing differences on
these covariance that you're using so
generally you probably want to avoid
p-values in testing the difference
between the groups generally p-value
isn't going to answer the question you
want to know which is have I reduced the
size of the difference it might it's
gonna tell you the likelihood or the
probability that there's a difference
this size are larger that's not really
what you want to know so generally what
people use is what I know as Cohen's D
it's also just called standardized mean
difference so you take the mean of your
exposed group after matching unexposed
group that has matched to it
and divide that by the pooled standard
deviation and so you get a mean
difference estimate in standard
deviation units it can be positive or
negative I usually look at the absolute
value over here down in the right-hand
corner just an illustration of what a
Cohen's D of one looks like what the
sort of level of overlap is there it's
most like excuse me
quite a lot of overlap and like I said
there's no clear consensus but 0.1 is
usually a pretty good metric to use but
it can it can vary depending on your use
case so this is just an example from a
recent match that I did so here on the
left is before matching so these are
just density plots for the unexposed
unexposed group very similar to the
ideal that I showed you earlier this is
totally coincidental
well it wasn't intentional at all but
you can see unexposed most of the the
probability densities pushed up against
zero but for the exposed group there's
actually pretty good support pretty good
coverage and then once you match you can
see the probability propensity
distribution so I should say
overlap almost completely it's
interesting
little kink there right around 0.5 it
probably has to do with the matching
algorithm but more importantly so
generally looking at covariance you want
to then go and check that you've
achieved your goal of getting balanced
so in the blue you have the unmatched
differences across these different
demographic characteristics so
percentage of male different age
categories or race ethnicity education
and so forth and and then the orange you
see after matching the size of those
differences and so the dotted line here
is that's a standardized difference of
point one so generally does a pretty
good job brings most of the differences
down to at least point 1 or less okay
estimating the treatment effects so a
lot of research on this topic a lot of
different approaches you could take here
so the general recommendation is that
once you come up with your matched set
if your supposed and expose you want to
incorporate the propensity score into
the analysis somehow and the basic idea
here is that the propensity score and
the matching isn't going to be perfect
there might be some residual confounding
you can add that score into the model
it's sort of a proxy for all these
variables you're trying to control for
it might give you a little bit of extra
bias reduction there's three general
ways that you can accomplish this so the
standard way would be a regression
adjustment right you have a model where
you regress your outcome variable let's
say we're talking about conversions here
on to some indicator of exposure or not
and then you include either a stratified
version of your propensity score usually
quintiles or you can include the raw
version there's also some recommendation
came from Ruben that if you run your
diagnostic tests and there's still some
imbalance there's lack of balance on
particular covariance you could also
throw those in
just just to be safe the last two
approaches so I'm gonna highlight these
there they're slightly different than
what I just described so stratified
analysis is a classic epidemiological
method for controlling for confounding
right you take some confounder you
stratify it again I think it was
Cochrane that suggested quintiles
and then you estimate the treatment
effect right comparing exposed and
unexposed with each within each of those
strata wait and pool the results now you
could do this after matching but
generally it's recommended or that this
this type of analysis came out of the
idea that you wouldn't actually do any
matching you would just do more of a
classic epidemiologic style analysis
where you would would do the
stratification I don't really I haven't
really seen that used either way much in
this literature but that was something
it was talked about early in the
development back in the 80s and 90s so
inverse probability of treatment
weighting this is a method also that is
become I see this actually pop up in
marketing now more and more it's often
referred to as the synthetic control
method and essentially what you do is
you fit a regression model and you rate
you weight it by the inverse probability
of the propensity and again you could
typically this is done without matching
so that would allow you potentially to
get sort of inference over the entire
range of exposed and unexposed you could
also do this on a matched sample my
general preference if it's possible is
to you know find a good match and
basically create sort of again like a
true quasi experiment where you have a
treated group exposed group and then you
you estimate average treatment effect in
the standard way okay
limitations and cautions so as I've said
multiple times this is obviously quasi
experimental method not an experimental
method and the ability to produce valid
inferences here depends on how well you
can account for key confounding
variables again I think theory is really
important here but it ultimately comes
down to I would argue can you
rule-out all plausible alternative
explanations for your findings okay and
I I want to emphasize this because I
feel like in the statistical literature
on causal inference that point gets lost
a lot and it's actually really what
causal inference is all about and again
I think having some theory is very
helpful to really think about what are
the potential confounds here whether the
potential threats to validity your
inferences are potentially based on a
subsample right of common support so
this area where the propensity is
overlap if you think about you go back
to the sort of machine learning ideal
where you have a very small area of
overlap imagine trying to do propensity
score analysis in that region maybe if
you have big enough data you could but
in a sense your inference would be on a
sub population that's right around 5050
and so it's a little bit of a contrived
situation in that way and it's going to
it's always sort of seemed a little odd
to me so that's why you really want to
make sure you have good coverage general
literature research simulation research
suggests propensity score matching is
probably pretty consistent pretty good
for directional inference so is there an
effect is it positive or negative
there's a lot of mixed evidence about
how easy it is to recover the size of
the treatment effect that you're looking
for so it's unfortunately there's no
again silver magic bullet pick your
preferred metaphor for this particular
problem and definitely your results are
gonna vary and so probably the best
thing you can do if you want to
implement this given the use cases that
you're dealing with is you know create
some synthetic data that are similar to
the data you're you're you're working
with relevant to your use case and
really just test different approaches
and do sensitivity analysis see what
happens by changing your matching
algorithm see what happens by changing
model specifications different
interactions and things like that I wish
there was a simple and easy cookbook
for this approach but it's generally
it's gonna take a little bit of work
upfront to get it to a place where it's
probably gonna be useful in your
particular use case just some resources
so perhaps not surprisingly there's not
a ton of packages in Python this is a
method that comes out of Statistics so
that's where most of the packages have
been developed but there's two packages
I found there's causal inference which
was looks like it was built about three
years ago I don't think there's been a
pull request in about two years so maybe
you want to make a pull request a PI
match is kind of in the same situation
it looks like it was built out for a
particular project it was developed
about two years ago and it I'm not sure
if it's even being maintained if you
want to just dive in you're not hung up
on using Python you can check out match
it which is an R package that does a lot
of this stuff theory and practice
the original article by Rosenbaum in
Rubin is probably worth checking out and
then more sort of applied articles this
article in particular Peter Austin at
university Toronto has done a ton of
research on propensity score matching
both different matching algorithms
different modeling approaches and so
forth and then this last article is a
really nice overview of really the
issues you need to think about it each
step in this process of trying to do
propensity score match okay I think
that's all I have happy to take
questions yes
that's a good question you're really
concerned with including and capturing
all of the potential factors that could
confound so it's a more traditional
statistical model where I'm just trying
to build the model that I think best
represents how some independent
variables or some predictors relate to
some outcomes so when I've used this I I
do very often use a light amount of
regularization I do a test train but I'm
not really trying to optimize anything
to be honest and I'm really just trying
to I'm focused more on what variables
are in the model and whether or not
those are the right variables to
potentially eliminate any confounds or
selection biases so you could use you
know scikit-learn it's not going to you
know be a detriment in any way but it's
not necessary either you can use stats
models just build a simple regression
model yeah so can you talk about why
it's used as opposed to a model where
like covariant matching yes so um so I
let me see let me repeat your question
back to you because I think I think what
I hear you asking is right what is the
advantage of a propensity score versus
just mashing on covary it's like in
their original form yeah that's a great
question so um yeah and it originally is
kind of the traditional approaches like
you have you know five background
factors you know and you just try to
match almost exactly or even in straight
out process but it quickly you run into
limitations on practically how many you
can
how many covariance you can match on and
one of the real advantages of this
approach is that you could have you know
10 20 30 40 covariance that you could
theoretically be matching on
simultaneously so in a way it's more
efficient it gives you more bang for
your buck and in some of the projects
I've done where
we have a lot of potential background
information there's no way there's just
no way you could do like a straight one
to one or even like sort of I guess you
could call hyper stratified match is
that answer your question yeah and like
I said the way I've always thought about
this is really nice as you're really
you're using this model to take all this
information and just get it down to one
number and then once you've got that one
number the matching is a lot easier oh
sorry that's not a question that's five
minutes left in terms of so the
propensity model let's say you had a
control condition and three treatment
conditions or you tighten or like a
kindy yeah yeah yeah yes you could you
could adapt it to that situation you
would basically you actually haven't
seen a lot of work on this I think right
now the general approach would be you
would you know let's say you had three
treatment conditions so you would build
you know 3-1 propensity models sort of
rate one against each build three one
treatment against control I've not seen
it done where the outcome is some yeah
some continuous variable that represents
maybe exposure in some ways yeah yeah
yeah I think you'd still need to like
categorize them in some way to create
sort of those those buckets those levels
but you could do it theoretically yeah
my question is if there's not enough
yeah that's a good question
um so you could try different model
specifications frankly to see if you
could increase that coverage probably in
a situation like that your best option
is something like inverse probability of
treatment weighting so that you could
use the entire sample and I think that's
why that method has become so popular
because it doesn't it doesn't need that
that overlap but yeah to some degree
you're kind of stuck I mean in an
interesting way it's it's that models
telling you that these are just two very
different groups that maybe aren't
comparable yeah yeah what is it called
again
Wang Wang okay yeah yeah and I should
say I've found one or two papers that
you try to use boosting to build the
propensity model not a lot out there but
yeah that's good to know